like do you think that's out of sort of
like a fear mentality I think she's got
a lot of guilt yeah she's got a lot of
guilt where
um she hasn't been able to provide the
way she wants to provide yeah she's like
I should be able to help you with a
mortgage help me the marriage and we're
like you essentially solely raised six
kids
um like we were all like at the point of
view where we're like hey it's our job
to look after you now like we turn 18
it's our job to retire you it's our job
to like look after you she's got a lot
of guilt and she's and I think it's more
that because of her guilt because of our
care for her that I'm like do you know
what if you don't wanna if you don't
wanna us to have kids I won't have kids
but I also I'm like
I'm too selfish at the moment and
selfish is a bad thing I'm too much like
if I ever never say never yeah I ever
had kids I'd want to be like I am happy
to commit all of my time I'm having to
sacrifice I'm happy to be like
financially you know you know it's
interesting they say that women around
like in their 30s all the ones that say
they don't want kids like start running
to a man I think apparently yeah yeah
like your biological clock apparently
like your hormones yeah it's like hey
time as well yeah but like I would very
happily adopt I I was training as a
social worker for a little while
um and even that like
that is like um
you know there was a lot of good if you
want a family you can have a family you
don't necessarily have to have your own
kids yeah but it's not really practical
for the average person I don't know how
much money you make
um so if you want to do like freeze your
eggs and have kids like that that's a
good and also adoption isn't cheap you
probably need like 20 grand to do that
like my parents adopted three kids
so it's actually
um yeah it's not an easy process no no
so yeah so for the average person it's
not really like if you want it bad well
pregnancy isn't having a family that's
it it's not cheap it's not easy but
pregnancy like it's definitely cheaper
than both of those options
if you want a family bad enough yeah
finances and that's that's the reason
why I can't have a family because I'm
like
financially like that's I'm like no but
if I wanted it enough like I'd make it
happen I don't prioritize it do you ever
um so going back to like the body count
thing it doesn't matter to you do you
judge men if they care about it
like do you think they have a right to
want what they want
um
I so I'm yeah opinionated but
non-judgmental so I'm like you know just
because I won't feel the same way as I
do I'm like I understand why someone's
point of view is that point of view like
it doesn't mean that I don't feel [ __ ]
about it like if a guy a guy once was
like I said to him I was like oh I've
done casual dating I've done casual sex
and it's like that's really unattractive
and what hurt me most is that I was like
well you didn't give me a chance to say
like
of what I am now like you've judged me
on like my past yeah but we judge a man
on their past yeah so if a guy said I
was unemployed for the last three years
we would probably judge him yeah yeah
and then I she was just like oh do you
know what like does it really matter is
this gonna matter when am I gonna cry
about this in two years time who who is
this man right yeah I mean I know that
you're not committed to who cares I I
understand like his opinion doesn't mean
I literally had a single conversation
with as well and he was like it's not
attractive to me that you've done casual
dating casual sex he was like have you
ever had a one night stand I was like
yeah I have and he was like that's
really unattractive and block me and I
was just at first like my ego my
self-esteem was a bit like what the [ __ ]
and then I was like okay but you've told
me that you go on a lot of dates but
it's a double standard oh yeah yeah yeah
so I I do think like men have the right
to judge us for that and I don't think
like women we could say we judge men for
it but it's just not true like women
it's um I mean you probably know it's
psychology pre-selection yeah so if a
man gets a lot of women like
historically he he would have been able
to like take care of a lot of women so
it's attractive to us and we can't undo
our biology right we are how we are even
if it's unpractical in this day this is
like Animal Kingdom um which is really
funny um so you've got like in the
animal kingdom if the Lions the male
lions have got the big Mane It's the
male peacock and there's liar Birds it's
the males who show off all of their uh
vocals it's uh there's a bird I can't
remember it's like a little Robin but
it's the men and they literally like
create a nest and the woman so a lot of
it is the female selection yes yes
um and I think in humans it's become a
bit like it's it's uh there's no back of
whites obviously in humans I think it's
the same thing the only difference is
that how we show our worth as males is
you know if we take the advantage points
that we know that women are attracted to
successful men we go oh look at my house
look at my car yeah the lifestyle that
I'm living that is all that's all the
same as peacocking basically for for
guys I would say
yeah
but success is also very subjective and
it also depends on like what it's not
subjective I don't know because your
income is like very very data driven but
I would rather have a man that knows
about the ego and has been through
therapy and it's like really healthy
than a man that's like so I've dated a
girl would you have you dated have you
dated a broke guy yeah yeah okay
why aren't you with them
um oh because of that what were you
talking about before the show
you broke up with him why
um
ambition not his money his ambition yeah
ambition and his inability to believe in
himself in me quiet
I grew up like when I I grew up in
poverty I understand I've I've dated a
very well like a guy that had a lot of
money but like didn't didn't do much so
I I understand what you're saying but we
can't we can't act like money is nothing
I'd rather make my own money you know
Neo is Miss Independent like yeah she
walked like like she she wants a man to
see him I am so ferociously like I am
gonna have my own mortgage I'm gonna
have my own like I'm gonna be that [ __ ]
that's like I've secretly got money on
the side so if you want to leave me if
you want to tune me I'll be good that's
such a fear mindset oh yeah yeah
do you think decisions made out of fear
are good decisions
[Music]
do you think that the reason you don't
care about right now how much a man
makes is because you're not looking to
have kids right now you're not looking
to settle down but if you were if you
got to a point where like look I want to
have a couple of kids and you know as
the woman you're the one who Bears the
children right you're the one who has to
time to take time off work so you're
gonna need a man who can provide for you
if you're gonna have at least a
reasonable comfortable life to have kids
so do you think that the reason that you
don't care about having kids right now
or you don't care about whether a guy is
broke is because you're not going to
settle down whereas if you did you would
care what 100 and that's why like when I
said that if I had kids I'd want to be
financially responsible I want to be
um so 100 yeah like I agree with that
because being selfish means that I can
be self-sufficient but yeah if I had
kids and I'm a very big I care more
about other people than myself so I'm
like if I've got me that's good that's
cool but if I'm having kids and
especially like if you're and yeah again
my own history my dad was a piece of
[ __ ] and could not Finance you before I
did all that kind of stuff but um yeah
like if if I was gonna plan on having
kids with a guy I'd be like yeah no like
I need to know that you can provide so
yeah it would definitely make a
difference if I wanted to have kids and
if that was where I was at 100 yeah so
then if we can all agree that we do
agree that most women want kids at some
point yeah yeah so that means most women
will always care about how much a man
will make always regardless how
independent she is regardless of where
she sits on the political Spectrum
whether she's conservative or liberal
whatever if a woman wants to have kids
with a man and she wants to build a
family she will always care to some
degree about how much he can make